yeah I just think self-awareness and I
feel like as a man you're forced to have
that you know I mean from early days
when you're in the playground you know
I'm saying if you're fat you're the
goalkeeper
it just is what it is you know I'm
saying like you get picked lost if
you're not the guy no one complains like
everyone kind of knows like there's
always there's an accountability there's
a hierarchy amongst men like we just
know from early like where we kind of
fitting in it like we live in a world
where
we get shown and told where we are all
the time and what what we are in it and
I just feel like for women there isn't
really that but I think their friends
just lie to them too much